okay let me see if I can
turn it on first
oh
the hell happened there
hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slow-mo
guys we've not done too much stuff with
electricity on this channel most of it's
involved sort of you know shocking me or
whatever yeah or a bit of lightning yeah
because I've mainly been waiting to have
access to two things at the same time
this camera
and this guy
hello hello how are you doing this is
Maddie from electroboom yes nice to be
here I like your videos yeah thank you I
like your videos oh thanks thank you
very much this stuff looks pretty
intense what have you got for us there
well I have a I have two things I have
my Tesla coil here it's a one Tesla
Tesla coil and then I have a Marx
generator here that I made uh hopefully
that will work I want to figure out some
stuff that happens to arcs in slow
motion and hopefully you can see it on
camera yeah so this camera will last go
up to we've only ever done a million but
it will go up to 1.75 million times a
second and the marks generator that's
the reason I originally got in touch
because I remember watching that video
what's going on and you see all the
sparks happen at the exact same time
that's what it looks like yeah and I
thought I wonder if they are actually
happening at the same time or whether in
slo-mo you would see their separation
hopefully the camera is fast enough to
capture like if it really happens at the
same time if it isn't fast enough we
will have failed you yes
we'll just wait another 10 years and
we'll try again okay we'll start at what
100 000 frames a second that's the
starting that's the starting point
yes ready
okay stop that was messing up the
monitor was it yeah that was that was
like making the money like zoom in and
you're like
because it's a capacitive screen oh
weird all right
[Music]
it's all over the place
oh yeah there whoa it's interesting look
at the little Tufts it's like furry
they're still so fast like look how yeah
look how long that takes I like the sort
of ghost it leaves behind do you think
the shape is it leaving behind a
condition of the air that means the next
Arc follows the exact same pattern
that's what I think it does yeah it
should it seems to be like the next art
follows very similarly the path of the
last one and it takes a few arcs to
actually significantly change like use
up that path well they will move the
thing is that the arcs will heat up the
air and the hot air rises so that's why
you see it
that's why it's like yeah that's why it
goes up but otherwise like because it's
not very continuous the air has some
time to cool down yeah okay but the I
don't know how long it takes for that
because it creates an ionized channel
right are you are you going to touch it
yeah it should I mean I thought I said
before it's not bad it's like somebody's
slapping you on the back of the hand at
one Hertz don't try the one kilohertz
it's like somebody is slapping you at
one thousand times a second
that's much worse you've known many for
what two days yeah
are you at that level of trust with him
yet I think I think can you not trust
this face truly no I trust you I trust
you so how far do you reckon it will get
me it'll probably go this far okay yeah
let me increase the power a little bit
you can touch it now and it will be
brighter when it jumps to you because
okay do you want me to touch it yeah I
think so I think that's going to really
help us see it then should I go first so
you're not scared or you want to go
first
I'll just do it okay oh man it's so
noisy just don't punch the Tesla coil
yeah okay let's have a look at that okay
all right okay let's see
[Music]
so now what I want you to do is to have
a screwdriver and point it to the arc
what do you think will happen will it be
worse or better
I can't imagine it'll be worse right
yeah because it's jumping to the middle
yeah and you won't feel it
oh yes why would I I'm insulating myself
okay yeah
ah oh you're feeling it like a little
bit yes
yeah the thing is that when it jumps to
the metal yeah because it's very helpful
voltage it will jump on the air to your
hand anyway so it doesn't matter oh yeah
I was shocked literally now hold it like
this but hold the metal tight so it
jumps to the metal and goes to your hand
directly right let's see how that feels
thoughts
I feel like I don't know what's going to
be worse and then I will increase the
frequency as well and see if it will be
much worse
you feel it
not at all huh nothing that's the beauty
of yeah you can go further out so it's
yeah that's if it's gamey though I can't
even tell if it's like no I can't see
the arc jumping you can see him
it's not very bright let me increase the
frequency so hopefully you can see
something
[Music]
yeah
where are you feeling it it was like
building up it was like no no it's good
okay why am I still holding it oh there
you go let's jump right it's brighter
when it goes directly to the screwdriver
isn't it yeah because instead of
splitting in many branches it just goes
in one oh they meet in the middle oh wow
okay see you see all the fluff between
the arc it seems like the arc is finding
new ways even yeah like there's
electricity going in little bits in here
looks like you're in space or something
like that so the voltage between this
speed and that bit is high enough that
arcs are jumping between the arc
from here to here yeah yeah it sounds it
looks like it yeah even at hundred
thousand
yeah it's done we need to go we need to
pump it up to a million or something
yeah
brilliant you know what can we do 1.75
million is that the maximum is that the
best you can give it's the best we could
do
I like jumping from a hundred thousand
to one point seven should we do it to
500 first I kind of want to see what
that looks like one million 500.
yeah we could waste time at 500 if you
want yeah
the Tesla coil breaks the air first it
doesn't see you it doesn't see the
screwdriver first it breaks through air
it makes channels through there and when
it comes close enough to you then it
feels like it has to jump to that yeah
yeah okay as you can see we now have a
very long and skinny resolution 1280 by
128 but we are at 456
000 frames a second so yeah about four
times slower than we just were we'll see
what extra information we can see but I
assume we will have to go faster still
should I go higher frequency yeah yeah I
can't really see anything yet
[Music]
okay so what was hurting me there it was
going so hard I was holding it like this
right and I moved it further away and it
stopped going to the screwdriver
yeah your hand was too close huh yeah my
hand was too close
is it oh it's not playing it's not
playing
I can see why I thought it was so slow
I'm not seeing anything okay so now we
might be at the point where we can see
the frequency maybe although you know
what they say if you want to sample the
frequency properly you have to be at
least double the frequency of the ah yes
because otherwise you would have it
turning on and off yeah within one frame
oh yeah okay here we go
foreign
is it happening multiple times
oh it could be it could be there all
right there you go
so we it might be the fact that it's not
exactly double the resonance frequency
if we go higher yeah it's definitely
blinking on and off after it happens
and then it comes on again then back up
then down then back up then down it's
obviously like building a charge and
then finding a spot to like nail and
just releasing all of its energy it's
quite a distance as well it's like four
and four or five inches
if you count the length of the arc
itself it's probably like six seven
inches it's going in curls why don't we
make the leap one 1.75 million just
straight up to 1.75 why not skip in a
minute skip a minute we've done a mill
before we've never done 1.75 million on
a phantom before that's true this will
be the fastest we've ever filmed on a
phantom that would be something yes and
you're here for it
this camera is now recording so fast
it's turning every one second of real
time into about 19 hours of footage
and we're recording for 2.2 seconds so
almost a couple of days
and find the footage yeah hello good
luck are you ready I am now taking
very casually 1.75 million frames every
single second that we're wasting uh
there you go you're immediately one of
the most photographed ones there is no
enough pictures of you to last forever
they're gone now though they're gone I
didn't keep it
[Music]
laughs
okay
I didn't see anything
we recorded 2630
minutes
oh my goodness wow
I'm excited yeah me too it's the fastest
Arabia I've ever done or you've ever
done yeah I've never done anything
wow
you can see they're drinking on and off
before it even makes it now you can see
the resonance completely so this is like
off on off on off as it slowly Works its
way over you can definitely see it
turning on and off throughout the ark
that's great you can probably calculate
the resonance frequency using this yeah
especially on that one even before they
make it we still see a few jumps from
the tip as well well we've confirmed it
too the air can blink at 250 kilohertz I
wasn't expecting that can you tell me
what is the frame difference between
this peak of the voltage to the next one
that way we can calculate the frequency
of resonance actually you can just see
it's 93 28 93 32.4 frames four frames at
what speed 1.75 75 million yeah it shows
430 kilohertz well I was expecting
closer to 250 kilohertz but well maybe
so it's broken
or maybe you are still missing something
yeah
they get brighter again oh no it is
right sorry I have to divide it by two
as well
so it's around 220 kilohertz on and off
yeah like it's AC so it's bright on the
lower negative Peak and the positive
Peak Okay so
yeah that's right
so the camera and the testicle aren't
broken yeah good everything's good we're
just looking at like pure
unedited
reality yes there's no lies it is still
you know an estimation because still we
are not sampling fast enough very
accurately yeah if we're down to
Counting four frames we kind of still
need to be going forward yeah we would
be good at like 10 million people yeah
I'm happy we captured the resonance
frequency I didn't expect that to be
possible
I'll keep the full fire the whole thing
save for how many friends save four
million 142 484 frames and I would say
I'll upload that unedited to the second
Channel but um I don't think you can
upload a video longer than 20 hours make
it a three-part video
yes so many frames it's almost one tenth
of the pictures people take off
themselves on Instagram yeah one tenth
of an Instagram influence yeah okay so
Maddie is now hooking up his marks
generator this is the thing I saw and I
just had to know whether all the Sparks
were happening at the same time or
whether there was a imperceivable delay
do you think this will work or do you
think it'll blow up somehow
discharges oops
did I break that oh no damn it I blew my
powers
now I broke down now I'll go solder
okay he's holding on she looks good
radio
high five
oh wow that's so bright
it like blew out everything over here
what
what's going on there so it's off okay
and on wow oh man okay so we need to go
faster I guess way faster look at how
bright that is is that all what is this
is this the electric fluff again look
all right don't know if it's this Flare
from the lens or it might be the fluff
actually it could be fluff hello it's
gab from the edit this is something that
we've all missed when we were watching
on the day just because the screen is
quite small and you can't notice
everything meddy discovered this
watching the footage back when he was
making his video this actually in the
final Gap a tiny little streamer just
slithering towards the other bead and as
soon as it hits it triggers the whole
thing I'm sure many will get into that a
lot more on his analysis video
wow nice okay should it go straight to 1
million 75
should we set this up
1.5 or nothing
it was so fast it was fast and bright I
mean not worried about exposure anymore
yeah okay we are at 875 000 which is
pretty much as high as we can go in
color
without being so skinny we can't see
anything
I can hear it
there you go
[Laughter]
do you think you'll have the
sequence of arcs or it's again one shot
oh there we go okay wow okay uh so here
we go flying back
it's all the same it's all instantly the
same bang it's exactly the same time oh
oh wait it's when it's turning on right
maybe that's just turn it off or on
which which one was it this is on oh so
the last one who went first so we've got
one in the last one for one frame and
then all the other ones are on
wow there are different stages though
like they're less bright here you can
see and then they're brighter and
brighter maybe as it starts right here
because they're closer yeah well maybe
it's because it's earlier it started
earlier so it's like it gets brighter
and brighter as we go all these capacity
stores would be at a different voltage
level so the first one will be a higher
voltage and goes down to the last one
but why would that was the question why
would the last one goes first and this
is a global shutter I always thought it
would start from the other end going
forward what no I'm going to pin the
sensor up to 1.75 million again
so our biggest struggle currently is
that finding our shot in the clip yeah
we want to react to something but
there's nothing to react to yes we know
we've got it
it's in there but we have to sift
through 4.4 million frames yeah you
really want to go up to 1.75 million
frames a second now look we're at
[Laughter]
oh there did you see did you see are you
serious no oh
I mean oh sugar 1.75 million frames a
second everyone calm down everyone
hold on now we will learn
what's so bright look at all the fluff
as well did it all happen at the same
time yeah it looks like it damn it why
are you disappointed in that the answer
is at the same time that's within one
what is the time difference there if it
was two Mega frames per second then it
would be like half a microsecond So
within 500 nanoseconds they've all lit
up at least so there's no lead in that
time either it was just straight up look
how bright that is we honestly need to
be filming at like 50 million prices
yeah it seems like it's a running at a
speed of light almost that has answered
my question on
my first thought when I saw your video
was like what would a phantom show yeah
and it shows
now if you go forward in time do you see
any blinking oscillation or it just goes
down like it's gone just calms down yeah
just burns the air away yeah it just
turns off for another four hours
well that's cool that was cool yeah we
were able to see we learned we learned
something we learned that electricity is
really fast yeah it could be could be
faster than we can manage here's another
couple of attempts that we didn't watch
on the day both of them display activity
in the final Gap well that was some
incredibly fast footage with some
incredibly fast action yeah I think it
seemed like relatively normal speed
footage yeah yeah boy well I'm just
happy my circuit was able to last as
long as it did it was stressful it only
blew up what twice no I think it was one
time three seconds yeah power supply one
second
yeah and that kept smoking what it was
just really interesting to see the path
that electricity chooses depending on
the previous spark and like the
temperature around it in the
ionization of the air it's incredible
yeah well actually what I learned was
that I didn't know air can blink that
fast at 250 or 300 kilohertz that's
surprising but yeah we actually saw the
frequency
yeah I love that you guys learned all
that and I learned that hot air rises
and I thought that would be kind of
obvious but uh
why does it always go up like that yeah
I feel like you knew it and then you
discover this it's like oh these are the
same yeah I applied it yeah yeah there
you go well I had fun thank you very
much for watching that video make sure
you subscribe to Maddie's channel it's
one of my favorite channels oh and
subscribe to these guys as well yeah we
have a channel it's you're watching it
thanks for watching it and we'll see you
next time yeah goodbye bye if you're new
to elektribute make sure you subscribe
he's already made a video and we'll be
making a second video where he in more
detail explains what's going on based on
the footage that he now has and I'm very
excited to watch it I'm sure it'll come
out soon so make sure you subscribe to
him as well